next figures e-coat inclusion from each
age
first I make sense organizers for for
invitation it's a great pleasure to be
here and so I would like to talk about a
special type of integer programs we can
solve efficiently and this joint work of
it with Jeff and Hartman and drop device
mapper
let's start from the very basic so it's
just a standard integer program the
objective-c constraint matrix a right
hand side B and all of them is assumed
to be integer and so there's a diagram
to the left to see am the cedar there in
a programming relaxation the blue set
somewhat optimized not over a blue set
but only the integer points in there so
the burette dots in there and the green
side you see is just the convex hull of
the integer points so I'll call this all
the integer Hall so this an of course as
many some some classes of programs of
IOPS we know how to solve efficiently in
particular if the number of variables or
constrains is constant or am one other
very important classes if the matrix a
is to lynnium order so again until the
model means that that any any square
minor of the matrix this tire is either
minus 1z or once any minor is minus one
zero the minor mean determinant of a
square sub-matrix and the reason why
that's the case is pretty a map is
pretty direct because if the matrix is
totally modular it turns out that the
relaxation to the blue set coincides
with the green side with integer halt
you can just solve the LP and return a
vertex solution and then it will do it
it's very important for pretty relevant
case and combinatorial optimization so
one could wonder it's a set so two units
means that miners are bounded by 1 in
absolute value so it's anything special
about one so one thing that certainly
special is that blue and green coincides
as I said but it turns out this an open
question or conjecture in the integer
programming community about whether you
could solve I hope is still efficiently
even if if a matrix which still bounded
miners but may be bounded by one with
bounded by a different say a constant
maybe even slightly super constant and
so it's clear it's kind of a this is
this minor
thus I stopped the term is kind of a
overweight to interpolate between the T
u KS and the general case at sometimes
some point things will get hard so this
latest happens when the the miners or n
to the epsilon for any constant epsilon
you can probably improve but just
something Falls immediately from
existing existing problems that are
np-hard
or so good so today I would like to talk
about the by modular case you can think
of this is the case where the miners are
bounded between minus 2 and 2 but it's
actually a bit more general and I want
to I want to present the result in their
generality so it's again integer program
but I only required at the end times and
miners so miners containing all of the
columns that they are between -2 and 2
furthermore neat that the rank of a is
that is a full column rank and actually
one can it's not hard to see that this
case includes the the case of all miners
being bounded between minus 2 and 2 of
course without the assumption of rank a
equal to n so it's not miss not
immediate there's like matrix S at that
property that don't have this property
one can easily reduce any ILP over such
a matrix to an ILP to a buy more their
IP caused by motor IP simply be IDs so
you see an example of how this could
look like such a problem and then to D
and of course now the relaxation can be
can be half integral that some so it's
not immediately obvious how to UM how to
derive integer solutions okay so the
main reasons I want to show today is
that actually control search by modeler
in different programs efficiently even
in strongly polynomial time and so sort
some comments and you can make an
example of other how you can try to
build up some intuition for this by
modularity order it is for for having
small niners so we will show that that
this VIP is you can reduce it to a kind
of a tu a total modular ILP with an
additional constraint of parity type
then we will you see musty decomposition
to decompose that the to matrix into
small into simpler blocks so I will go
into those details in there in a second
it sounds a bit confusing at all try to
enlighten this port soon a crucial tool
BMF use of abusing schema see you
decomposition maybe break the problem
down into simpler problems and those
problems can then be interpreted
combinatorially that's kind of an
important step we have reviews here and
then we need combinatorial procedures to
solve those and the procedures we need
or our capacity constrained community
total problems and actually one of the
main tools we'll use this particular
strain some other minimization so this
the task is to minimize a some other
function over all subsets that has all
kind of a and it turns out that's one of
the few classes of
strengths of other minimisation for
which we know how to solve them
efficiently okay
let's simmer before it's get into the
into the proof of that statement let me
talk a bit about if a bit of intuition
maybe about a pound of miners so here's
an undirected graph and the vertex such
incidence matrix so you could wonder
what is the what is the highest miner
you can find in that matrix and of
course if the graph is bipartite
corresponding matrix is to you then the
highest miner will be one if it's not
then you could try to find odd cycles
let me try to give an example here so in
this triangle here an odd cycle let me
mark two of them they're two vertex
disjoint out cycles and so this clearly
shows the graph is a bipartite of course
but also reveals a larger miner so you
can do is look at the at a vertex such
incidence matrix and just look at the
miner corresponding to the red edges so
the sir take the columns corresponding
to red edges that would be M hope I
don't do it wrong if I do it wrong
please let me know you 1 2 3 & 6 & 7 & 9
so those columns and I look at the
vertices that are incident with those
edges so this is vertex up to 6 so 1 to
6 so what you will see here is you will
see a fellow cut this at the sub matrix
so it's actually a block diagonal matrix
because I chose to Burdick's is shown
triangles this is one block of it and
that's the other block of it so this has
been 1 3 x 3 block and all the
off-diagonal entries are or 0 so of
course the I mean the determined you
here have the instance matrix of a
triangle so it's the determinant will be
2 or minus 2 it's to an absent value the
same down here so the this minor I
exhibited right now has its maps in
value equal to 4 more generally you see
that construction if I had found like
caber exist on triangles the minor would
be in absolute value to 2 K and it turns
out is actually not just one possible
way to find large minors and should a
lot the largest - look look like that in
that matrix so so the largest minor can
find in this incidence matrix is
actually equal to 2 to the power of the
so-called odd cycle packing number which
is really just what I did
which means how many triangles how many
odd cycles can you pack in a graph
disjoint so it's a matter of how far you
are away from a bipartite graph and
particularly fuel cycle packet number is
1 then this matrix is totally by modeler
so total means that all minors are
between -2 and 2 and this means if you
can use our procedure to am to optimize
any ILP over that constraint matrix so
we respect our constraint matrix in
particular we can find a maximum weight
independent set for such graphs so for
graphs adult cycle packet number 1 or or
a minimum vertex cover so those
questions have been open people started
to study to the maximum pencil problem
in the context and the proximation
algorithms are known but in for the case
of odd cycle that a number equal to 1 it
was not known how to get the maximum
weight independent set prior to our work
this is many more resolves on small
minors and I'm gonna list just a few of
them and I just mention them briefly or
even if there's no way I could go into
the all this very very nice works so
it's the old cycle packet number I
explained it turns out that's it for if
your cycle packet number is constant you
can actually you can actually recognize
such graphs that's a non-trivial
procedure that's based on work of all of
Seymour and Robertson Seymour and also
if you have a polyhedron that's defined
by constraint matrix with bound minors
it turns out one can show that first the
diameter is small and also there's
actually a randomized simplex type
algorithm that that for solving a LP s
over such polytopes this results by the
by what alters and particularism
fritz who's who's here this results in
computing a largest minor as i've two of
them but they're many more they also
result in computing largest minor under
some additional constraints and the
thing we later have to talk about in the
sheet this week they will also be about
that topic and there's a very nice paper
by by hope almond and Shanti Kumar
showing that such of several things
essentially a framework a present but he
really have the implication for our
setting the show that if you can solve
for example vips optimally or or any ILP
with some bounds have found the miners
then you can even solve the same problem
optimally if the objective is separable
and convex if it means can minimize
Apple the convex function we kind of use
as a black box the algorithm and then
replace the linear objective by a
separable complex
the only difference between the general
case matrices I mean it
I see I mean in a VIP can also have
negative numbers it just doesn't this
example is because an incidence matrix
when directed graph it's it turns out to
be zero one that that's a let's read
just the example that it has a property
that's nothing that's not really nothing
military with the definition of
something other matrix here that's
pretty simple actually
that's sorry that's right if the court I
can imagine you fall Flyknit like a
proven in two or three minutes yeah
good more questions many okay that's uh
ma'am let me tell you a little bit more
about the approach so I'm gonna explain
the approaching a high level so it's a
bit if I wanted a lot of technicalities
and I try to I try to speak many of them
under the rock but I'm a but I would
like to give you some of the main
ingredients we need so we start with
there with a VIP you see over here so as
a general VIP you see the server
typically assume it's a political to be
a polyhedron er an unbounded possibly
unbounded we've actually first solved
the LP can a vertex solution for the
corresponding LP and I will always
assume that the vertex solution is is
not integral and of course if that is
integral I'm immediately done so let's
assume it's fractional so it's all
integral from decades and then we will
be the first show we can reduce now the
VIP to a different type of problem which
I like to call chronic parity tu problem
or CPU so it's again it's an ILP it's
some special structure the constraint
matrix T is tu the right hand side is 0
some particular it's a chronic one so
the the origin is tied with respect to
all of the constraints and of course
it's so far they would that would be
easy but there's one additional
constraint which says that for some
subset of the coordinates s you have to
be if you sum up the values of Y over
those coordinates it should be out let
me give an example so if a to the
example and so they're polyhedron so if
a cone actually that cone does does come
from a geometric so it's not hard to
check and let's assume that that the set
as is just the first coordinate this
means you want to optimize over the
integer points in that cone but not just
any integer point you want that the
first coordinate is odd so when optimize
overall or the solid points I've been
here because of that ordinance
constraint the origin is not feasible
it's actually never feasible for those
CPCB two problems it's kind of important
because the origin will correspond to
the LP optimum so we do want to cut off
that solution so then having a CP two
problem what we will do is we'll you see
mostly composition on this Q matrix T
the decomposition allows you to UM
allows you to okay that's as far as it
gets and allows you to decompose a teal
matrix into simpler matrices it's a
purely structural is all about two
matrices that was actually developed in
the context of regular matrix was a
topic that's close to my heart matron
optimization
and and then you show that not just can
you second new city conversation not
just to decompose the matrix but
actually I can decompose the problem
itself as well along this decomposition
level get into that a little bit maybe
at the end of the talk if I if time
permits good okay let me first start how
can you go from from a VIP problem so
from a buy order IP to a such a chronic
problem in a tu matrix again I'm gonna
mostly highlight the main the main ideas
so this is and there's a key result per
vessel of intercom that says the
following look at any at any be IP so
essentially just there is all about the
feasible set so forget about the
objective glennyb IP that canny vertex
so here maybe it helps to imagine that
this would be like an an optimal LP
solution but that could be any vertex
now if you look at the tight constraints
at that vertex so this defines no a cone
and look at the integer hall of of the
points in that cone then it turns out so
this is now a polyhedron with some
vertices in this case we have we have
two vertices it turns out that these
vertices lie on edges of the relaxation
axis of the blue set of the blue
taxation of the beginning
I wonder why shouldn't even care about
that the the point is that that's pretty
powerful and sense it for it implies in
particular that those vertices are
feasible for all of the constraints the
first are integer because I said it's
tainted for also other integer points
but moreover there in the blue set in
the relaxation so they fulfill all of
the linear constraints therefore they're
feasible so this means essentially you
can you can for example so let's also
what we actually do you can solve the LP
get a vertex and vertex solution forget
about all the other constraints that are
not tight then you optimize essentially
the optimum the rat set here over the
integer points and for the cone or
convex off those points if you return a
vertex an October tech solution to the
new problem you'll be done because it'll
be feasible for the original problem and
of course the rat set you have here is a
relaxation of the original problem so so
you'll be immediately be done if you can
do that so that's an that's a key accuse
old actually you can forget about all
constraints that are not tight on
there's some mild conditions if to make
sure we return a vertex
yes oh yeah that's the hard part
yeah so it's the problem where I'm man
I'm a non-degenerate right then you
could just look at all day I mean at the
predominately many are many many raisins
and just check where the first integer
point lies and return the best one
exactly yeah that's really about if you
see about finally generous man
fortunately most commendable problems
are highly generates okay so I'm
supposed to let me the second example
dose of debt theorem so let's pick
another vertex let's look at the tight
constraints let's look at the convex
hull of the integer point so that's case
so this time is it's a cone it doesn't
need to be one and there's one vertex
and that vertex is on an edge of the
original relaxation okay so I'm so let
me make just just sketch that hope you
go to see P Q so if original VIP problem
I solved the LP get a vertex V
a look at the type constraints now
invoke vaselov ensure covent and throw
away all the other constraints are not
tied and I end up here essentially I can
assume as a pap problem that's conic
it's essentially about an easy way to
explain that now what I will do is I
will do column operations on the matrix
or the new system and they'll do
cooperation such that you obtain an
identity matrix on somewhere in in in
the constraints and so this will
actually correspond to do a an affine
transformation off of the variable X
into new variable Y and what one can
show is so then we you get a clue we
first get a new system of type and some
new matrix times y smaller equals 0
every one can show that this matrix is
actually tu it's kind of interesting as
follows from let me Ramon property it
could help you understand why this this
makes sense as soon as you have a conic
cibecue Brown sorry iconic VIP problem
then if it take any full rank and times
to take any n times n full rank sub
matrix then it's determined has to be 2
or minus 2 because those constraints
assume full rank they do define the
vertex V if determinant was like 1 or
minus 1 I mean it could just obtain B by
inverting that matrix and multiplying it
with BQ and then I would have an integer
vertex but I know that that mean is an
integer so this cannot happen the
special structure we have here so all
the N times and minors are
actually not just between -2 and 2 but
there are -2 0 or 2 that's an additional
structure we didn't have beforehand and
this is actually we can exploit to get a
few matrix is what what what explains
that this will be a 2 matrix I don't
have time to go into those details now
okay listen F to make sure enough the
transformation but I have to make sure
that if he now optimize over those why's
that if I transform it back into acts
that I get an integer point X right
that's what I'm interested in and it
turns out if you mostly just some
calculations that the condition you need
to the by needs to fulfill that this
wholes is precisely a parity condition
and that'll I will skip this an interest
of time so it turns out the condition of
the ad is that for some subset of the of
the coordinates a y of S has to be out
summing Y of those coordinates has to be
out but let me a man let me skip this
okay now that talked a little bit about
see mostly decomposition that comes in
the context let me start with a general
explanation of what I see mostly
decomposition as I said original is
presented for regular matrix but is a
like very close relation between regular
matrix and tu matrices and so it turns
out the lint in your matrix can be
decomposed into simpler matrices simpler
to your matrices that are one of three
types either network matrices so can
think of I don't define informally but
you can think of them as as directed
incidence matrices of a graph this is
like one special case of a of a network
matrix and it's a slightly more general
more general class or somewhat more
general class so some matrices you would
see in a flow problem transpose a
stare-off so the matrix is you would
seen in a cut problem and these two very
special 5 times 5 matrices and so that
way you can get down to those simple
matrices by a set of operations which
are listed here again don't want to go
into all of them some are very very
simple operations like in prim you'd
rows and columns it can negate or column
but the most may be among the more
interesting ones are sums with one two
three sums and maybe can explain here so
if a to matrix that can in such as you
can reorder rows and columns in a way
that that you feel like now almost block
diagonal matrix I'm explain the twosome
so if I have two matrices on the blocks
and but you still have a rank one matrix
here in an off diagonal block then we
say a to dis or to some is defined this
if you
right this matrix as LA's raised as you
find a right inside and T transpose R so
we say that this is a the to sum of
these two terms is 10 this it's almost
block diagonal matrix and similarly a
threesome does a similar operation where
you have to rank one matrices in the off
diagonal dogs and the one sum is a very
trivial compositionally 2 and actually
and diagonal dog a block diagonal matrix
and it's important here is that so
similar one can actually easily quite
easily see that if this matrix is 2 u
then both some student on the left hand
side or tu as well and vice versa and
that's true for all those sums actually
what people also use this for this new
decomposition is that one can recognize
a working one can prove to the matrix is
tu occasionally also given a sufficient
certificate by using a to decomposition
and if we're gonna make sure whenever
you decompose you are map preserved two
units there's kind of one of the initial
other motivations in the context of to
use and the one more operations kind of
an important is you can do pivoting
pivoting is kind of I think of simplex
pivoting now let's keep the other ones
for okay it reaches a structural theorem
but I want to do it then I've on a kind
of used is in the context of CP two
problems but let me first explain so how
does such a decomposition now look like
so again let's forget about the simpler
operation that just assume you have only
one two three sons and and pivoting
ebony so get a teal matrix and you can
actually there's some tree somebody
composition tree that looks like that so
there may be first a threesome that you
composes the matrix into T 559 so the
threesome of T 59 is T then if you if
you keep pivoting on T 99 you get ta
which in turn can again be decomposed to
the threesome so it looks somehow like
that and the leaves you have here those
of the T 1 T 2 T 67 and T 4 so these all
except for the root there would be one
of those three types explained
beforehand the network matrices
transpose a stare-off or one of the two
constant size matrices
so he'll show is the following we will
show that if you consult the CPT problem
which constraint kind of CPU problems
the kind of can and solution procedures
can propagate bottom-up so first we show
that actually for the base blocks or
those three types of matrices we can
solve CP two problems efficiently if the
constraint matrix of the CPU problem is
one of their of the three base block
types of tu matrices you also show that
for any one two three some if you have
an efficient procedure for any CPU
problem on the matrix TI and one for TB
then we can get one for TC so for the
three some of the case some of them BK
is one towards the same for pivoting so
this is kind of a an easy kind of a high
level simplified way of explaining that
there's still a bunch of caveats oh nice
to watch out for one is it's not just
sufficient to say that if you have an
efficient procedure for CP T with
respect to TA and TB that you can want
for TC because maybe the the
computational time will increase by a
factor of n potentially and this
decomposition can actually be is kind of
non constant depth this will not lead to
an efficient algorithm for CPU 440 on
top so when someone has to make sure we
have something stronger than just saying
that if efficient procedures below then
you can get efficient one for the next
one for for one two or three
and let me give me some details of how
he am how we do that let's just look at
it to some let me just remind you of
where we are and where the to some is
and then what I want to do so yeah we're
given a CP to problem here again T is a
T matrix the right hand side is 0 and
give some some parity constraints and
let's assume that T can be written as a
to Sun so T can be written as from LA to
some B transpose or this means it's it's
an almost block tango matrix for the
rank among one matrix here in the one at
top right so so the the components in
which we have to be art they can kind of
be split into a left part and the right
part we'll call this the SL the left
part nasur the right part and when you
look at that problem it's somehow it's
nice that it has almost block diagonal
structure because they would somehow
decompose the problem into the left
variables and the right variables right
because it's almost no interaction it
was just two types of interactions we
have one of them is for oddness on the
set s right if if you said you can think
of an of a solution to a problem is
consisting of XL of a left part in the
solution we have this from here of X are
like the components correspond to right
part so to make sure that that if X L is
all done as L then X or is even on s or
and or vice versa right so it's like
some interaction here and the only other
interaction we have is a rank one matrix
up here but that's that's it so what we
show is we show that actually exists an
optimal solution to the CPQ problem that
has the following property if your
search you can decompose into the left
and right again we can think of it that
way we can show that the scalar product
of of be with the right part is minus
one zero one slice is useful if I told
you this is the if I told you what the
scalar product is it's a I tell it's one
and there's no interaction anymore
between left and right part here because
you know what the Emma may you know how
to modify force on the Left problem you
know whatever the impact is of the right
problem on those constraints up here
because they only depend on that scalar
product nothing else right it sounds
nice it seems like we can kind of the
kind of like six options we could guess
just like three options for for am what
the scalar product is
there's two options on whether the right
part is all dinosaur and the left one
even on a cell or all the other way
around of course in simply procedural
pictures to enumerate those six options
and solve the left right part
independently this would indeed lead to
an efficient procedure for the problem
up here if you can solve the left and
right port independently but it turns
out you have a problem because CMOS you
decomposition doesn't really and and
doesn't give you a lot of current
teasing about how those how big those
make this island or or I mean how how
balanced they are they could be
extremely unbalanced it could be that in
for such an imbalance case where Alice
almost the whole matrix and or is a two
times two matrix in this case you
definitely do not want to solve the CPQ
problem we like six symmetry problems on
the on a matrix L because they're almost
the same size as the original problem so
this would lead to again now we would
fall into that trap I explained
beforehand that if you then propagate
things up this will not be polynomial
time it's actually also need to tweak a
little bit similar decomposition to make
sure we have properties meaning
and good so if we do is the following
let's assume that the right part is a
smaller part in a sense maybe with the
right matrix has a smaller number of
rows we kind of measure measure the size
in terms of rows but there's different
ways to do that then what we will do is
we will look at the six options of the
scalar product and the odd-even version
and only solve the right problem for all
those six options but the problem is at
most half as large as the as the
original one so this we can afford
actually and once we solve those six got
six solutions we actually we will show
that you can now redesign and you can
build up a new problem on the Left chord
then incorporate those solutions from
the right part and so the left part just
once which avoids the issue of having
exploding complexity so also skip is an
interest of time
so I'm so the main message is clear we
can solve VIPs efficiently actually even
in strongly polynomial time and there's
a whole bunch of interesting open
questions my opinion and first we cannot
recognize by modern matrices or totally
my mother matrices so if you give me a
by mother matrix and then I can solve
any ILP over it but I can still not tell
you about your gave me a bit more their
matrix it's kind of a strange phenomenon
so we am of course a big open question
is can you solve chemotherapies what
about if the minors are bigger than two
may be constant K can be so soft them
efficiently seen for K equals three
that's open it's an answer right and you
can see and then it essentially can you
can check whether the answer is is I
mean if something would go wrong if if
the matrix is if you give me a bad
matrix yeah I maybe not the point is
that I mean you could give me an on by
mother matrix but they're different but
it could maybe it will still give an
optimal solution right one one reason
could just be that if I solve the LP n
look at the cone that is tight there
maybe this part is by modeler and the
non by molarity was somewhere outside
but it we may know the reasons for this
was not be a big issue but there many
other reasons that that could they could
appear so you don't know am the tree
does imply much your goodness me play
much in terms of recognition so hires up
higher higher case interesting medium
just determine feasibility if I give you
like a 3d model or ILP just tell me that
it's feasible or not I've no one knows
how to how to answer that question and
so turns out what we did is we somewhat
reduced to came out there is a tattoo
modeler the buy more die apiece to
actually secure the motor optimization
problems like I said beginning there's
some other minimization parity
constraints because what we do is we go
we broke things down in this seems to
decomposition to base blocks to base
matrices and those problems are
extremely common at Oriel then we can
actually use combinatorial procedures to
to direct the main work and it would be
nice to see can we get a similar
reduction for higher K so it turns out
that so super higher K you would have
problems that at least capture problem
constraints of this type we want to be
for example one mod K for on some
coordinates
but I don't know a reduction it goes
both ways all such problems will appear
you have to be able to solve them but
I'm not sure if you cancel if done
better you could solve any any kind more
than LP actually we can extend some some
independent work with multi Nagaland
penisula coffee
we can extend the result that you can
efficiently solve officially minimize
some other functions over apparently
constrained you can show you can even
efficiently minimize them over any
constraint of type that the cardinality
is is K mod P where P is a constant
prime power this is kind of this does
extend kind of the of the the world and
the constraint types or which you can
efficiently minimize some other
functions and may be useful for the
depression will be nice of a different
approach then for solving Bips that it's
not based and see most new decomposition
first of course it's certainly slow but
also structurally would be nice to have
an approach that is and that that is
different that's one thing we can
exclude such other work with IMAP we
have foreign travelers and chef and belt
care we can show that actually be IPS if
you look at the convex all of the entry
hall so they can have a very high
extension complexity and actually even
even just a cone a VIP cone can have a
high extension complexity so I mean at
the integer Hall of of a VIP cone so
this is certainly not such an approach
to certain of workouts to try to find a
small description we can clean show
something more we can even show that
even if you have you're even allowed to
use up to almost square square root log
and a square root and many integer
variables near in your ma in your Excel
a description and even then you're not
able to describe it with very small
number of of constraints so maybe
somehow when I see a parity constraint
you might think maybe you could use
integer variables a few of them and
could describe it so it's not work out
and also be nice to have maybe
additional structure properties of came
other matrices open there thank you very
much that's all I see
so when what do you know when when does
it start yeah so it's an certainly at
any for any constant epsilon if the
miners or n ^ epsilon that it's
certainly np-hard and I don't know if n
is anything stronger than that but I
also didn't didn't try that hard to
prove anything stronger than that it's
not no yeah but potential can improve
the power saturation is already known
for a man a baby don't get that but it's
known from mother work yeah this is the
old assault by thing Louis inscriber but
I think it's not written up and for for
the for the outside back number of one
and then this is a coverable yeah she
and and read paper that actually shows
it for any constant any constant not
psychotic numbers this is a pretty
interesting
thank you thank you
[Applause]